[Music]
welcome back to stanford welcome back to
the gsb
ten years ago
you would have been sitting out in those
seats contemplating your graduation
just six weeks away
today
you founded newbank the world's largest
digital bank with over 50 million
customers
and uh valued almost 30 billion dollars
so behalf of all my classmates sitting
here today i really just have two
questions for you
what
and how
we we do have a lot to cover so so i
want to get started
i want to start before the gsb uh you
grew up in colombia then moved to costa
rica you're in a family of entrepreneurs
with your father and your uncles how
does that shape you
well first of all i'm so honored about
that i mean i don't even know what to
say it's i'm really speechless it's a
it's an honor to be back here at
stanford
um as a gsb alum and undergrad this
place is super special for me i made
some of the best friends of my entire
life
and it's been incredibly influential so
thank you for having me and and you know
excited to be telling a little bit of
our story
um
i
as as you said i come from a family of
of entrepreneurs i grew up in colombia
my dad has 12 siblings
my mom has five they were all
entrepreneurs there were small
businesses
and it was all about hustling
all the time
every time
i
had to be my my dad had a small button
company
uh for jeans and i was working the
button company doing quality control of
buttons when i was four years old
and i was i grew up in that environment
where it was always about problem
solving it was always about leading and
about um
not necessarily following rules but
questioning when the rules don't didn't
make any sense and trying to open
space to
solve those problems and i remember one
day i i don't know
i had a conversation with my dad about
like what are you gonna
be when you grow up what are you gonna
study and tell him i'm gonna be a
manager thinking that was the the best
thing uh where i'm gonna start
management and he said no no no no no
like what do you want to manage
you're gonna be a founder you're gonna
start a business you're gonna build your
own space and so
i think that was that was the the dna
that i grew up in i was very lucky to be
here at stanford undergrad
and
the the i think kind of that radar that
everybody has about trying to find what
to start what business to start was
always on
to my own disappointment the first year
half pass and second pass and third year
pass and i had no idea what to start
and to my own disappoint i ended up
going through more traditional
financial services experience but i
loved it i learned a ton i worked with
really really amazing experienced people
and eventually uh through a long story
and i'm sure we're gonna talk about it i
finally had the shot at at a building i
started building the company i was it
took me almost 15 years to figure out
what to do yeah i want to get to that in
a second but first you mentioned after
some time in investing uh with general
atlantic and some banks you came to
stanford
came back to stanford came to the gsb
what were you looking for from the dsb
from this place back then let me ask it
a different way what mattered most to
you and why back then
yeah so that is
that's a tough one to write
so i think for me it was um so i wanted
to start something to me going back to
business school was okay fine it's done
like i really need to start to get ready
to build something
and um and it was also about latin
america and i think related to that to
the question it was like
impact
i
at some point
i realized that two things were really
drivers for me one was learning i had to
always feel that i was learning
something new and i felt that my level
of motivation quickly declined when i
find myself that i had mastered or i had
learned or i was not being challenged
so but then beyond that it was almost
about like what's the what's the meaning
of what i'm doing what what what's
ultimately
what i'm doing every single day what is
that driving towards what is that
creating
and um
when i was uh initially when i was doing
investment banking was i was learning a
ton and getting out of the comfort zone
but the what i'm ultimately driving to
was harder for me to answer
moved to ga when i was closer to the
entrepreneurs that was easier to answer
but ultimately i was not building it i
was sitting in front of the entrepreneur
and i thought of the entrepreneur what
the entrepreneur was doing is like i
wanted to be that person i wanted to be
the one that was making the hard
decisions not necessarily telling them
what to do but actually doing it myself
and and ultimately to what i wanted to
do is
what i wrote in the essay was just
create that impact to build something
and but back in latin america where i
always felt that there was so much to do
and so much to build that i that i
needed to be able to tie back what i was
doing to that overall impact in the
region right
and yeah so while at the gsb you were
still investing working for sequoia
focus on latin america um
and after graduation you stayed in
investing
uh went back to sao paulo but within a
year less than a year you had found a
new bank what happened where was that
switch
so i started uh
full quarter at stanford ready to start
taking on the classical entrepreneur
ready to enjoy my two years of partying
and you know and learning and thinking
and then one afternoon david george
who's around tells me you gotta go meet
dougliani at sequoia right here mr doug
and
he's they're thinking about investing in
in uh in latin america and i of course
went and met dog at sequoia
and uh and a lot of a lot of things were
very odd about the first encounter
generally because your first interview
in any place generally is with the most
junior associate with the youngest
person
here i was talking directly with the
head of the firm and and that was not
usual
and then i sit in front of the dog and
we had just a great conversation for for
60 minutes
a lot of conversations about about
family a lot of questions about personal
very
uncharacteristics of a venture capital
interview
i later realized that it was all a
psychological profiling that that was
happening at that point
uh
and and um and doc told me come back
meet other people at sequoia and let's
see what happens and and between
between me leaving sequoia and getting
into my car i already had an email from
michael morris say come back i want to
meet you it took five minutes for duck
talk mike and mack and and send me back
and so
in in two weeks i went and met everybody
and and they proposed me to
help sequoia look at latin american and
brazil and so at that point
i wanted to i wanted to start a business
but this was just too good of an
opportunity to to to say no to i was
going to be able to
be closer to entrepreneurs as a venture
capital investor i was going to be able
to be very close to some of the best
entrepreneurs in the world that
operated around this area seeing them
being there as they pitched so sequoia
so the opportunity was too good to pass
and decided to put
again once again uh paused the startup
idea and spent
effectively those two years uh working
at sequoia how did you balance that for
the current students here
what was the day like
it was it was incredibly intense uh
there
there was an advantage that brazil is
five hours ahead
so i had to
wake up at four in the morning so that
brazil was was at nine and ten i was in
the office at school offices at four
four thirty calling entrepreneurs and
talking and sourcing like crazy and so i
was working at sequoia from
five to eight a.m would come to gsb
would have all the classes done
then go back to sequoia until like i
don't know 6 7 pm then go back to go
back to um
back home and try to do
uh some homework i think the video said
that somehow i was perhaps close to rj
miller's color no
not even close you had you had to
sacrifice something there is no way you
can and i quickly recrea you know
sacrifice this is not this does not make
any sense i cannot do that i'm not gonna
do hundred percent of the readings
impossible uh i'll pick and and i'll
take the risk of
the professor calling me on a class and
not having the answer because i didn't
read everything
i'll embarrass myself but you have to
give something up you cannot do it all
and
and uh that's that's what i ended up uh
giving up so
and and uh there were no tuesday nights
uh a party for me i i wednesdays were
the day off
and that was that were some of the most
uh kind of really surreal experiences of
getting picked out at gsb going to the
airport getting to a plane with dog
flight to sao paulo landing wednesday 8
a.m
having 10 meetings signing four term
sheets get back to paulo and be back on
thursday for gsb so then i would pinch
myself
being in a plane saying what it's what's
happening here but um but anyway it was
super intense but you had to be able to
to balance it somehow to to to make
everything work right you talk about
giving something up you end up giving up
invest investing right and making that
switch
what was that decision what was going
for your mind
so there was
there was a really good advice i got
from doug at some point that made me
thought a lot and and kind of
conceptualized something that i was i
had already been thinking for a long
time and i'll just give an example to
talk about that i i remember
right after right before business school
going to a conference in new york a
venture capital conference
uh latin america venture capital
conferences and seeing one day eight
private equity funds in latin america
pitching their fund
in my end at the end of the day it was
like every single pitch is exactly the
same
there was no differentiation everybody
was pitching the same strategy
and then there was
an advice at some point that i heard
from dog is
and it was very also timely about what
was going on in silicon valley in 2012
is
that you want to position yourself in
the side of the scarcity of the market
not in the side of the oversupply
and where was where was a lot of our
supply there was a lot of our supply of
investors at that point in latin america
trying to do
there's a lot of our supply of people
like me in the us
and so
me staying in the u.s was being
positioning in the area where every
where i was a commodity i was a complete
commodity in the u.s my background what
i knew was
too many competent people in latin
america that's not true there is a
scarcity of talent and then where's even
more scarcity
we went and met a lot of startups
there were few startups and the few
startups that they were trying to do
were almost like clones of u.s companies
they were not really solving the real
latin american problems they were uh
one they were
when we went there were three thousand
clones of groupon in that time
that's not the biggest problem of latin
american is is getting figuring that out
or or
uh when
that's not what people really care about
when you don't have banking access where
there are no hospitals when their
education is horrible when there is bad
infrastructure so they're all these
gigantic problems and there were no
entrepreneurs actually
solving them or addressing them
so when you combine all of that it's
like this is where their scarcity lies
is these huge challenges in latin
america
i can position my surface strategically
to be able to address those and
ultimately that meant also stopping
investing and ultimately going as an
entrepreneur to to build something that
was very ex different at that stage yeah
so you mentioned you wanted to solve
difficult problems you chose banking
which is highly regulated
in particular america has a lot of
entrenched players in particular in
brazil why banking and what were the vcs
telling you about that when you're
pitching that idea
yeah so um
so a couple of a couple of reflections i
think i i had some time
i going back to what really were driving
me the big question was like what is
impact how can i how can i optimize the
amount of impact per unit of time
i'm going to start a business it's going
to take decades right it's gonna be it's
gonna take as much energy to do
something small that something big
and when i asked the question what is
the single most what is the single
hardest thing i can possibly imagine
what is the single most impactful thing
i could possibly imagine
banks was that the answer because when
you look at latin america
the biggest companies in brazil are
banks the biggest companies in mexico
are banks the biggest companies
argentina our banks there's nothing
bigger it was it was the hardest thing i
could imagine it was the single most
impactful thing i could imagine because
these were it's an oligopoly structure
is your five banks that own dominate 80
90 of all these countries
when you have an oligopoly you have no
competition that translates into some of
the highest interest rates and fees in
the world
really horrible experience
and
significant percent of the population
not having access to anybody not being
able to get into bank account everybody
will serve them so
if i managed to figure out how to bring
more competition to that industry make
it five ten percent better by competing
with these five
giants then the impact of that was going
to spread around to entire region was
going to be really really impactful
so uh
so i arrived to that from from a very
kind of uh
very high end think about that impacting
question
no idea really how to do it it seemed
impossible we i went and talked to
i think i had like 30 meetings coffees
in sao paulo with the former ceo of this
bank the former ceo of the bank
the consensus overwhelming consensus is
no you cannot compete with these banks
it's impossible
these are
the banks they're more powerful
corporations in latin america they are
controlled by the wealthiest families in
latin america
they will never let you compete they
will go after your kids they will go
after your family
a lot of people
have done it but then a lot of arguments
that that
just didn't make any sense and i would
like listen very carefully trying to
trying to filter out
the nose because there was real reality
behind the nose and the nose that were
just
ultimately a symptom of consensus and
fear
and there were things like well italy
tried to do an online bank in 99 and
they failed
that's why you're going to fail
and i was like
we're in 2012
60 million people have a smartphone 99
you have five percent internet
penetration and that was the argument
that the experts were telling were using
to tell me that people would not use or
internet in brazil is very slow and then
you had 100 million people already
you've been
brazil top five in the world in
instagram and facebook and youtube so
a lot of arguments that the experts were
proposing
against that idea but when you think a
little bit deeply about them they would
be very weak underneath and ultimately
my my my conclusion at the end of maybe
two months of talking to people was wow
there's so much fear
there's so much fear about competing
with that that's all what is driving and
obviously technology was switching the
opportunity if it had been 2010 to
compete with those banks i needed a
billion dollars to put branches in every
corner
and by ibm mainframes the right time
kind of the wine now question smartphone
created removed all those barriers and
allowed us to use technology to to reach
100 of population so it was a confluence
of technology
uh getting to the right time but then
also kind of as an outsider and i saw
myself as an outsider i'm not brazilian
i never worked for a bank in brazil
i was not consumed i did not grow up in
that environment where
people were fearful of these big
companies i didn't even know a lot of
these controlling families that my
brazilian friends knew and feared
being having a being an outsider looking
in was ended up being a huge advantage
because
allowed me to disentangle a lot of those
arguments and ultimately realize that
there could be an opportunity there yeah
but from that idea
to traction is a long road right when
did you know that you were getting
traction with the consumers the ones
making the decisions every day yeah
so at every stage uh yeah we we got the
first million from sequoia it was a huge
bet
on
the eve the region on on the
relationship i had with doug
that helped with with kasich who put the
other million but there were so many
open questions that i couldn't even
answer and there were so many points of
perhaps complete failure so for example
there were two issues of credit cards
one of them when we went to them and
said hey we're starting this
fintech nail bank said you're crazy no
way we're not gonna we're not gonna work
with you the left one left
and when we went to them they said yes
so if they had said no
we're done
uh
there were there were changes in
regulation that came in and at every
single step there were
there were points of failure but somehow
with with a small team we were creative
i remember
we
there was a new law that that appeared
in brazil the new regulation that made
us effectively force us to launch three
months before
in april 2014
we were going to launch first card in
june and the regulation changed and said
if you're not operating april 2013
you will need a banking license uh which
means it will take you three years to
get it which means you'll be dead
so we grabbed the entire team and said
forget the timeline
survival mode
april we have to be live and we have a
timeline
and it was so
crazy that
to be able to match the timeline
perfectly we had to get an approval from
mastercard the right time and it was
only approved in in holland
fedex was going to take two more days
than me flying in an airplane to holland
and giving that
sheet in the headquarters of mastercard
there so we would get in a plane and fly
to holland to give one
uh to give one pace to somebody
mastercard because that would save those
two days from fedex so that was the
level of urgency of trying to figure out
how we survived so we could launch those
products that time so we launched some
time
uh we had the 12 cards up on the routing
up and running with tough employee we
had 12 employees
uh went to the corner shop
paid some coffee obviously as always
didn't work the first product
everybody's appointed everybody was sad
when oh what's happening eventually we
ate already worked out
and then with the serious we raised the
serious a
and then that was going to be the coming
out kind of announcement we're going to
have to do a lot of pr
and we're going to opening up the
company for external employees external
consumers
and we had a the day we announced the
series a and we opened the website we
had an internal bet about how many
customers are going to sign up
and some somebody said 1500 a thousand
somebody else said 10 000.
the average of the employees was a
thousand
we announced
we worked really hard to get ourselves
our name there in the big magazine
we got 200.
completely disappointed everybody went
home sad oh my god what's going to
happen like people don't want everything
is wrong
and then a couple three months three
months happened we were getting 150
people there
the the year passed
and then there was one one day
unexpected one very niche publication uh
it was not the main newspaper one niche
application that went after the the
design community and engineer community
talked about the card
and suddenly the following day we got
three thousand people and the final day
we got six thousand and the following
day ten thousand and suddenly growth
just started
going out of control to the point where
we were completely unprepared and we
created this this concept of waiting
list
which then created even more scarcity
which meant more people wanted the car
which created more
so that's when i that's when i always
started to think that they when that
publication came in and all these people
started i was like whoa okay
there is there is there is something
here yeah well so it's incredibly here
this journey and there's a lot of
budding entrepreneurs in the audience
like let's check who here is working on
a business or thinks they're going to
work in a business after graduation
so get us
even more than i thought um
what's one thing you know now that you
wish you knew when you were sitting out
there
ah so a lot a lot of different things um
i i think we did
when we looked at that industry and when
all this expert told us
no
our approach was
forget experience
we don't want experienced people we want
complete outsiders we want to reinvent
everything from first principles
everything from the way the product
works
collections we did not want to hire
somebody from the collections agency of
the big banks we reinvented collection
from scratch we did not want this core
banking systems of the industry we built
the core banking system from scratch so
it was all about reinventing the entire
industry from from from scratch and that
meant hiring people that are completely
outsiders
that worked well but that did not scale
and that that became a significant
bottleneck as we started scaling and
that also ultimately meant
reinventing the wheel in a number of
different things that frankly we just
didn't need to reinvent there was a lot
of
um there was a lot of
good people in banks that could bring
the good people in collection that could
bring they want and save this a year of
reinventing collection from scratch
so that complete dismissal of experience
was too extreme
ultimately i think what we learned was
you needed to figure out how to how to
find the right balance between the
outsiders and the insiders
how to find the insiders that were still
able to to think
as a beginner
we always say that we like to hire
people that have more questions than
answers and we continue to look for
those people that have more questions
than answers the person that comes in
and has all answers that has 30 years of
experience we don't want that person
even now
but even
the insiders that can ask a lot of
questions they're very
very valuable because they know the
enemy within
they saw all the
vulnerabilities they saw the things that
could be better but they can still have
the the the kind of the beginner's mind
of of reinventing a lot of a lot of
products from scratch and so what we've
increasingly done and as we scaled the
organization we had we've been actively
more looking for those insiders that can
help us reinvent
and especially as you start
really tackling
scale problems how do you build
engineering systems at scale how do you
build customer service scales the data
science machine learning systems of
scale then you need to rely much more on
experience it doesn't make a lot of
sense to be trying to reinvent so it's
all a balance but i would say having
been able to find the right balance
earlier would have saved us
a lot of pain right
so you mentioned people and i want to
talk about something related to that
which i know you talk a lot about which
is culture
you talk about having kind of the
founding team then expanding how do you
maintain the new bank culture
uh that the company's so famous for
one one of the
so i mentioned earlier how i impressed
about i was with sequoia and how
different a lot of the things that
together were so different and and
one of the things that i also
reflected
while i was in doing the internship is
i had never felt myself so motivated my
entire life with any work and
in previous jobs i felt that i was
always at
maybe 80 of my capacity 90 percent my
capacity at the beginning of being
pushed and learning
at sequoia in the first few months i was
100. it was clear to me there was no
there was nothing more and i was and so
it made me think like what what is
what is driving this like what are they
what's different about this place that
is driving somebody like me to to want
to go at that at this pace and working
for dog that's driving me to go out this
at this speed and
exactly what's the
delish
uh
and it was not and it wasn't that that's
that's amazing it's not the it's not the
whip it's it it was this
first it was this sense of ownership it
was i was an intern from business school
and i had the head of the firm
investment committee asking me what i
thought about a deal
nobody in my previous experience had
asked me what i thought i was this is an
analyst
in the first investigate sequoia as an
intern i sat next to doug and he asked
me what i thought and i didn't know i
didn't have an opinion ready and that
meant that for the next one i better be
prepared i better knew like i had to
give a good answer
and so that level of autonomy with
ownership was a really interesting
conversation that they how flat the
organization was it was not all these
layers
where
the ceo was over there it was like
everybody has the same room remember
mike moritz didn't even have an office
he was he got us a chair in the hall and
and you're like talking in with
so
that to me was like that was culture and
that was and culture was driving that
motivation
and the other thing i heard a lot about
sequoia that i was able to learn when i
was sitting in front of this
entrepreneur was
hearing a lot saying that the culture of
a company was built in the first six
months by the first 10 to 15 people
so when i started newbank the first
thing i did was
the
pitch deck for the city but the second
thing i did was the culture deck
and this culture deck was like the
constitution what are what are the
values of this company were about to
begin to do
and had a lot of elements that that i
had learned at sequoia this level of
ownership this autonomy this flat
organization this this this view that i
personally thought
drove
a lot of motivation and since the first
10 15 plays were so important and they
were very as as we hired them with my
co-founder we were very actively looking
for
people that had brought that dna and we
co-designed this culture deck with
everybody of them from the designer to
the first engineer they all participated
in the construction of the deck
and this was very powerful because in a
way sometimes i think about it as
the constitution of the united states
the constitution of the united states is
over 200 years
it's very short it represents what the
us as a country stands for and here we
are and it's still
people still go drawn to that
and for us that deck was the
constitution of newbank and today those
values are as latent as important for us
as they were when we were 10 employees
so that has scaled a lot that gave us a
lot of clarity around the people we
wanted to hire about the way we did
performance management the way we let go
people that drove all decisions that
drop product decisions that drove the
type of language we should use in an
email with the consumer
or focus number one is this obsession
about consumers that meant hours of
debate about the words that we could not
use with a consumer because they were
too complex
about the level of simplicity this
ownership
of everybody flat that meant customers
calls
would go initially to my co-founder
christina's phone and my phone i would
get customers the first quality was not
a customer service person i was getting
them in my phone
so
um so i think ultimately that kind of
became a bit of the realization why
culture was
what it is the driving force there's
nothing more important because
culture allows you to hire people people
build products products bring your
customers
and so ultimately consumers don't come
to you because of your products
consumers come to you because of the
culture
they're consumers of culture they're not
consumers of products
and really authentic
companies are companies that are able to
really
ultimately represent and show
what they stand for and obviously more
importantly
they have integrity they they do what
they say they do this there's perfect
alignment
and this is perhaps as you scale the
part that we've been much more mindful
about
uh
the the expanding culture has meant we
have a number of different routines for
example this culture deck that i
mentioned i still present that culture
every month to everybody that starts a
new bank
since the beginning
uh till now
it's me i don't delegate that to anybody
every month i present this culture deck
with the values to every single person
from the customer service the
receptionist to the engineer they all go
through this onboarding session with me
where i present them the deck and i
think that shows
the the level set the lack of hierarchy
the the transparency
that shows how important culture is the
values
but then
every single time about thinking about
the decisions you make you have to bring
back those values in
so i'll just i'll give one last example
on uh just just to to exemplify this
about a year ago one
one team came back and said wow
something is happening
we're making more money per customer
suddenly the cohorts the new economics
start increasing
you see a leap of revenue per customer
we went and looked and tried to figure
out what had happened
and it turns out that through a bug in a
system some an engineer had removed an
email
that reminded the customer to pay on
time
and so obviously customers were being
laid more and we were charging more late
fees
it was
very simple for everybody to know
what to do because we had a framework of
values
that provided context around that
decision the right thing to do was not
only go back and put that email
but also go back to customers that have
overpaid and told them
sorry we made a mistake we removed this
email that you should have received
we're not gonna charge you this this fee
and here's your money back
you know and that's to me was a really
powerful example because first
99 of companies would have done the
exact opposite they actually would have
said ah let's see what our email will
remove right
this is great let's take this email out
let's take this email out to make more
money
even companies that say they're consumer
obsessed would probably have had a lot
of really tough conversation of somebody
saying
the customer should have known it was
his responsibility like you should
for us it was was clarity
we want consumer obsession put that
money back there was put put that email
back
and and then the the answer ultimately
is like it's a teaching mind for
everybody's like why does that make
sense and why is it consistent with the
business
because when you're a consumer and and
your bank is telling you this you say
i will never go anywhere else for the
next decade you got me forever nobody
else would do that for me
so and that exemplifies very well i
think what we think which is ultimately
this this culture is aligned with
business objectives
we get to retain that customer for a
decade now because we
reimbursed a dollar in a late fee
so ultimately that is a very powerful
example internally yeah and and and and
shows the integrity of the culture which
is
actions speak louder than words and
in this example ultimately exemplified
that very well yeah i want to switch
gears a second and talk about latin
america a region that's close to both
of our hearts
as you mentioned sequoia pulled the plug
in latin america in 2012 because of a
lack of tech and entrepreneurial talent
and last year they came back into latin
america 2017 new bank opened an office
in berlin to attract tech talent right
and now we have a classmate of mine out
in this audience somewhere
whose gringo's gringo gets
and is moving to sao paulo next year to
join your team
there's a transformation happening but
how far do we still have to go
uh it's um
it's a it's a it's early so it's early
days there's a lot of work ahead i think
the future of every
industry in every country is technology
companies like there is no way back and
i think it was obvious in
retail initially with amazon and then
companies like netflix and media and
companies like uber and transportation
every single vertical of the economy
will be owned 10 20 30 years from by new
digitally native companies
that means that
every single industry you see today in
any country in latin america is going to
be reinvented and sometimes will be the
incumbent that we'll be able to reinvent
that will probably much more the
exception on the rules but there's a
huge opportunity to reinvent all
economies in all industries
now who does that reinvention
entrepreneurs
and very much
engineers at the end
we're starting to finally get
entrepreneurs in latin america hopefully
all of you even the gringos go latin
america and and start businesses
because 12 years ago that was not
happening people were going to the
consulting firms people were going to
the big companies
and and and the few entrepreneurs were
just again looking at the clones looking
at this this stuff but there was a lot
of opportunity reinvent banking brain
brain healthcare reinvent telecom brain
bent transportation
now engineers
it's that's a big big big problem very
unresolved uh is one of the reasons you
you if all industries are going to be
reinvented in latin america there are
two options by tech companies there are
two options or they get invented by
latin american technology companies
or will be american and chinese
companies that will be global and will
be in a town
if it's latin american companies you
need engineers and they're not engineers
in latin america they're not i remember
with doug university of sao paulo
42 computer science engineers graduating
in 2013.
brazil
graduates i think something like 30 000.
i was looking at the numbers in colombia
a couple weeks ago
there are more there are 10x more
graduates today there are 10x more
people studying law in colombia than
computer science
doesn't make any sense
and what's what's strange is you would
think initially you would say the lack
of this bottleneck you think it's a
supply issue nobody's teaching these
people how to become computer
engineering
it's actually a demanding issue these
students are graduating from from high
school today and they're still choosing
to do a business administration or law
when there is about half a million
gap of computer scientists in lifetime
which is more or less the the the the
the bottleneck so
unclear how to solve that there is a
it's a big opportunity or a big
challenge if we don't solve it
there'll be chinese tech and u.s
companies owning all the industries in
that time
because somebody's going to do it
if we solve it somehow we we grab
all these people there's a huge
opportunity to
not only
reinvent all the economies in all of
these countries
but also to contribute to solve one of
the biggest problems that we have which
is opportunity and income inequality
because if it's just a few companies
from abroad then you have this extreme
concentration of of market cap in some
of these companies and you don't have
the latin americans contributing to that
so you will end up with much much higher
income inequality if you solve it then
you have all latin americans building
their own
programming and design and product
creating the next company that are going
to be reinventing all this region so
it's it's almost like an existential
threat
for all countries right now
globally
same thing happens in africa same thing
happens in asia the problem is that i
would say latam and perhaps africa we're
just farther away
and in and even though i think here at
stanford for us it's almost like this
clear now what's happening in the next
10 20 years you go to any you talk to
the
student that's graduating in high school
in guadalajara or or in salvador in
bahia or in cali
they don't they don't see it they
haven't they don't know what's coming
they haven't seen it yet
speaking of inequality uh your wife
mariel is here today as well and
together last year as dean levin
mentioned you were only the second latin
american family to sign the giving
pledge
take us into the conversation you were
having together
what motivated that decision
so
i think
we
always
we did newbank as i said because we
wanted to build we wanted to problem
solve we wanted to create impact
and it was the sheer kind of joy of
creation and and and creating impact
and so money was never a motivation it
was never really something that we
thought about it was not an issue both
marielle and i come from families uh
middle-class families that
gave us a lot of opportunity and we feel
very blessed about the opportunities
that we had
but money per se was not was never
really a driving factor
and then suddenly these companies start
is being worth a billion dollars and
five and 10 and 30 billion and this the
speedies
is huge and then about 12 months ago we
we
raised money at
25 billion valuation and and you start
making the numbers like wow this is a
this is a lot of money
and we don't need it we do not we don't
need this money we don't we don't need
it we don't live a luxury life
we don't we don't we don't we don't need
it and and it just feels like a big
responsibility suddenly because we we
come from going back to impact that's
what drives us
and um and then it becomes a big
response like how do you
use this money to provide the biggest
impact possible in the region you go
back to the same driving factor the
impact question
and i had read a book uh that i
recommend everybody to readings one of
my more impact impactful books called a
billionaire who wasn't chuck finney the
founder of atlantic philanthropies
where it's a fascinating book where he
goes for 20 years doing philanthropy in
the world he decides that he wants to
spend it all while he lives all the
money
and he says that he wants his last check
to bounce
and i just thought that was the most
powerful
analogy and when we started thinking
about it
we said
we want to be that person
because if you start thinking about it
first what a great opportunity all
society is going to change and we're
being benefiting significantly from the
change of technology but second this is
just going to drive significant income
inequality
and so um
philanthropy and social impact giving
back plays a role but why delay it
why delay this to the end when you're 80
years old when you're tired when you
don't have the energy when you don't
necessarily bring like the quality of
mind to solve
problems even worse why
dying and leaving all that money to a
foundation of people
that will do it
or to your kids where a lot of the times
that is just going to make more damage
to them than good
uh so we decided we do not want to leave
it to the kids they will be loved they
will get a lot of opportunities but
living
living a lot of the stuff it's not
that's that that we don't want to do
that so number one not two kids
uh they're young and they're not looking
at this but maybe one day they'll be
they'll be they'll be very resentful i
hope not i hope they'll get to
understand why we're doing this
so number one number two
we're all dying
at some point we'll have there will be
one day where we won't exist anymore
and um
i think it was sandra carnegie who said
who dies rich dies disgraced because
there is so much pain in so much
problems we saw in the world today it's
like why would you delay it why would
you not use all that money
now to solve those issues why would wait
decades
if you can do a make a difference using
your energy your mind and your and your
in your money to do that
why die and risk not you participating
of the of the solving of those problems
so
all of that
there was a big kind of brainstorm that
led us to this decision that
we want to give it all away
we want our last check to bounce
and we're going to be thoughtful about
it we're going to set it the right way
we're going to build a family foundation
we're going to go back and use a lot of
the tools that stanford and business
gives us of
think back on first principle think
about all these problems what is driving
this inequality where is the highest
impact per dollar expense in the region
and how do we how can we over the next
four five
maybe six decades
use this
this money and this energy to create as
much impact as possible
and um and so that's where in the very
very very early days of of that journey
it's a very interesting question
um i think philanthropy needs to be
disrupted there is a lot of lessons on
we're
we see ourselves with danielle here
who's also our gsb who's helping us that
we find ourselves
in meetings using concept of computer
science
in philanthropy use talking about
platformization talking about open
source talking about crypto
and there is a lot that can be used
to start addressing some of these big
problems and ultimately not let this
technology become
one more driver of inequality but
actually have it
be an enabler of of more equality of
opportunity for everybody great let's
actually end on that note for
[Applause]
now um
[Applause]
incredibly inspiring and uh a motive for
action i want to go to some audience q a
i know we have a lot of questions so um
first questions right over here from ben
uh thank you very much for being here
i'm ben goldwater mba class of 22.
um
one of the reasons i'm very excited is
i'm coaching someone who tells me he
wants to be the next to you in 10 years
so financial products have there's kind
of two sides to each coin
you can help people but those products
can be damaging i'm thinking about
consumer debt you can give someone
access to resources
but interest can be crippling i'm
curious how you think about what
products to launch and what guard rails
you should put around them
yeah
no it's a
it's a it's a really good question i
think
going back to the culture
knowing that we are consumer obsessed
first and we're doing the right thing
for the consumer allows us to move back
and then
define the product
versus what happened in a lot of the
banks which is
how do i make more money by this product
and just launch another fee or increase
the interest rate or or you end up what
you see in most banks where you have
110 different fees if you look at one of
the big banks in brazil
their fee table is 110 different things
two cents here one one cent here 10 cent
here you send me a text message i'll
charge you
we went and said
zeros so our feed table is just a bunch
of zeros
so we start with this simplicity and
transparency of the business model and
figure out how we can create a
sustainable business model that provides
a lot of simplicity and transparency
and then
specifically with credit then there is a
lot about um
aligning incentives
we're being fully align incentives
we only win if we provide a credit
a line of credit that's going to work
for a customer because
we get to maintain a customer for a very
long time if we provide the wrong
product at the wrong price for the
customer that customer will be in
massive debt
but we'll also lose a very great
customer that we could have in in in our
base
so um
that just means that it's great
underwriting it's fraud underwriting
it's using a lot of sophistication
around modeling is a lot of simplicity
in the language lots of transparency in
the communication with that customer and
always trying to
be fully aligned with with with him or
her
great next question
over there
see andrea with uh class uh 2002
i'm a founder of venture capital firm
auto tech ventures
and so question to your cultural
behavioral
managerial style
so a lot of companies are struggling to
transition from let's call it flat
organization with free flow of
information and very egalitarian
decision making
into more structured businesses once you
scale you need to create business units
you need to create responsibility and
accountability and reporting verticals
what would be your advice at what point
you say okay i cannot be flat anymore i
have to verticalize
and do you have any recipes how to
protect the culture and still maintain
the culture of this open exchange
as your organization scale
yeah now it's a it's a great question i
i talked i said about the culture deck
and how little has changed through the
years a few things have changed
and
and one of them was
again going back to this mindset of
trying to reinvent everything and think
everything from first principle we came
in and said we're a flat organization
and our deck said flat organization
and
um
that was a really bad idea
it turns out that if you're completely
flat and you and everybody has an idea
it's it's complete chaos and you become
really slow and and everybody and you
end up with these systems of consensus
where everybody needs to agree it turns
out consensus is actually a driver
towards lower risk type of decisions
which means you end up with a lower risk
type of organization
and
and you also end up with a very you slow
down the your product so
so one after seeing all this happening
and you always go back and kind of
question yourself about why does this
make any sense
and kind of the realization was a bit is
like hierarchy is a good thing there
isn't there's fundamentally nothing
wrong with hierarchy hierarchy has
existed in human organizations for over
5 000 years almost every organization
has a hierarchy because hierarchy is a
very useful way to organize a larger
group of people what's not good is
hierarchies that
are created sometimes for other purposes
rather than
doing the right thing for the
organization or doing the right thing
for the product
and what what what are some of those
things
we
remember going in in sao paulo in our
building when we were renting a new
building and i got in a question from
um
the architect of our new building saying
if we needed a special elevator for the
directors and if we needed to reserve
the last floor of the building for the
directors and i had no idea what that
meant
until i was invited for lunch at a big
bank and i saw myself going through a
special elevator to the top floor
that was for directors and i had waiters
with white gloves serving me
lunch in uh in in a silver platter where
everybody in the organization else was
not eating food
and so that is the wrong
reason to build
is symbols of power and ego
and a lot of organization
ends up being corrupted by the ego of
the founder by the ego of the directors
of of symbolic power is the big corner
office
of of the ceo when you have a little
cubicle
or having a special
parking lot for the ceo
why i would love to go and i've never
done it i will someday go to see one of
these big organizations like explain me
why having that
restaurant only for you and that officer
how can you tie that directly
to better business performance
there isn't there is no way to justify
those divisions through better business
performance is ego
so i think that's when your organization
hierarchy ends up being a bit corrupted
because it's just more ego and power and
titles that are driving a lot of layers
rather than
doing the right thing for your
organization so
we have a hierarchy it's as flat as it
becomes we try to organize ourselves in
autonomous units but with a clear leader
that has real accountability we don't
believe anymore on
group decision making we want
everybody's input we want to hear
everybody but ultimately we got to make
a decision and there's got to be an
accountable person to make that decision
so we can move
we don't believe in consensus
necessarily if consensus arrives
excellent it doesn't we have to make a
decision
and and then you have a hurricane with
as many layers with clear lines of
accountability in the organization and
that allows you to to drive fast but
ultimately it's all about business
performance and driving to results and
it's as egoless
and title-less as possible so you can
remove that from the day-to-day
great we're almost out of time i know
there are more questions but
unfortunately almost out of time
but before we close uh we want to do a
traditional view from the top lightning
round you ready
ready
colombia did not qualify for the fifa
world cup
who are you supporting
brazil
that that's the that's the wrong answer
um let me try again i get again um i got
four brazilian kids now so i got
all brazil messi or ronaldo ronaldo
okay we should move on um favorite class
at the gsv
dr feely
dodgeville
biggest learning from that class
it's it's a simple insight but really
really really powerful which is
success is driven by people is by
by being able to if you are better at
relating with other people that's a huge
advantage because
uh everything you do is with people your
family is managing people you relate
personal relationships people your
companies are people your teams are
people
and uh and ultimately that and
be able to create strong bonds with
people through vulnerability and through
knowing yourself well is a very very
very powerful superpower yeah
um worst piece of advice you've ever
received
bonus points if it's from doug
yeah exactly
don't
launch a detail bank in brazil because
unibank failed in 1999.
um better parties stanford undergrad or
stanford gsb ah
i
think gsb
yes um
we can all relate to that last last one
favorite memory of the gsb
um
favorite media
at the gsb
i think it was
uh
it's there's just there's just so many i
think it was just being in our house
past that house
uh appropriately named animal kingdom
with some someone starting all these
animals right here animal kingdom
uh with illusion of animal house and
just spending time with friends having a
beer in the afternoon grilling a burger
and having just a great blast with great
people
ladies and gentlemen please help me
thank david velez thank you
[Music]
you